Okay.
So we have these two guys in the ring
and we know already how to solve the
elimination equation. The elimination
equation, we don't measure radiants,
we measure intensity.
It's not really a unit and physics,
it's just some top thing
that happens to work.
Okay?
In the rendering of the equation,
we measure radiants and we have to do
some kind of integration. And this is,
if you, the more you think about it,
the more impossible it will soft too.
Even the thought of solving this problem.
So the first question is,
what can I earn by solving this equation
because I have to be motivated to do
it. So obviously there
is all better, be better,
look really good in order to be of need,
the motivation and the
resources to solve it.
So this is an itch from the first
assignment and this we have computed with
recursive ray tracing. So
you can see, for instance,
hard shadows and you can see that
this is a reasonably boring image.
I mean,
it's great compared to the
simplicity of the model that we have,
but it's not really the
greatest. Well, what is missing?
Let's take a look and look very closely.
Let's take a look at the very same scene,
but not with recursive ray tracing factor,
global illumination logarithms.
So not the illumination equation,
but the full rendering equation.
Take a look at the difference.
Look closely.
This is full global illumination.
Ah,
finally. Absolutely beautiful.
Let's take another loan.
This is recursive ray tracing
and global illumination.
So apparently there are some effects
that recursive ray tracers cannot account
for. What are these events? Well,
we have talked about indirect
illumination or color bleeding.
This is the very same thing.
This means that I am hitting to
diffuse objects one after each other.
Is this visible enough? Okay. I'm just
pulling things on this earth. Are you guys
okay? Perhaps slightly better,
right? Mm hmm. Yes. Yeah. Okay,
cool. So these are in this
case led parts. What's that?
What does it mean?
Everyone knows you start out from the
light source to him to diffuse objects and
the GTI.
Excellent.
Now, indirect illumination
is all around us, everywhere,
both in the real world and both in
the better computer games out there,
which have the approximations
of indirect elimination.
And you can see that on the left
image it almost looks like Photoshop.
It is completely
okay
alien from its surroundings.
It is almost as if he didn't take
into consideration in surroundings.
They are standing in the front, in the
middle of the desert, not just somewhere.
You would have to have some color bleeding
effect that you get from your son and
this is what usually the problem is
with many of the fall shop delicious.
You just reviled the person from somewhere
and you put it in a photograph and it
looks super fake and yes,
mostly because of the
illumination conditions.
But even if you try to account for that,
even if you tried to recall to have more
at the same color scheme than than the
rest of the photograph,
you're still missing the interactive
combination effect and the human values
very keen in recognizing them.
So you recognize that something is
wrong but you don't know what exactly is
missing.
And it's usually indirect illumination,
but there's something else.
Let's take a look at this scene
with recursive ray tracing.
So we have refractive materials.
For instance,
this plastic sphere on the left of
your spirit in the middle and they're
completely and a diffuse
sphere under right.
Let's take a look at how the
very same scene looks like.
What would the domination,
this is the difference one more
time because the freight tracing
and global illumination,
so like we have talked about this before,
I can see that differences
in interactive elimination.
So on the on the upper left I can see
that some of the rent collar is bleeding
on to the other wall and the very same
with the green wall in the background.
Also with case diffuse balls.
So even the simple diffuse sphere looks
much more interesting and much more
beautiful
with global illumination.
Don't say anything,
but I say something else.
I see something else as well.
Not only indirect elimination.
I see some other effect on this image
that I couldn't compute with ray phrase
search before.
Don't say anything.
Raise your hand if you know
what I'm talking about.
Excellent hours that we want and
what don't say anything. Okay.
All right.
I'm talking about this and this.
So this interesting
light effects on the wall and
being oldest, the glass sphere.
So raise your hand again if you know
what, what, what this is exactly. Okay.
Don't say anything because so many people
know you will have to say all of you
at the same time after
three. Got It. Okay.
So everyone, one, two,
three. What is this? This motion?
Yes.
Okay.
What are any other guesses?
Infection.
That's technically your fraction. Yes,
but that's not how we call the offense.
Anyone else?
Yeah.
Okay. This is what we
call costings. So what,
what kind of life path is this? This is
an interesting life path in this case.
This is l s. S, t, e. Y.
Because we started out
from the light source,
we hit the glass sphere from the outside.
Then we have refraction,
we he did from the inside and then we
hit some diffuse object that is either
this checkerboard down there or the red
wall on the left and down to the eye.
And if we have this effect down,
we are going to have costings.
It's the beautiful,
beautiful phenomenon in nature.
Yeah.
That we can find the account for and it's,
hmm.
And then you can, you can see
this at many, many places.
No.
Let's take a look at another example.
This is the famous school
corridor example from Luxor under.
Okay. We have requested rate
tracing and global illumination.
So you can see lots of indirect
illumination. This, this reddish light
on [inaudible]
the floor and perhaps some costings or
at least caustic looking thing in front
of the lockers. Yeah. So next question.
What is the definition of shadows again?
So what we have said before that shadows
are regions that are not visible from
the light source.
Now,
an alternative definition of
shadows is the absence of light.
This is what definition we will using
global illumination. So there is,
you could say that there's no such
thing as shadows. There's no, uh,
but that's, that's not something,
that's just the sense of something else.
If there is less light somewhere,
then there's going to be shadows.
So this is the definition of Cheryl's
in local illumination and the enzyme
culture.
And take a look at this image.
We can see some beautiful,
beautiful, soft shadows.
And the thing is that you don't even
need to do anything to compete DC
illumination. So if I have
a ray tracer, what do I do?
I shoot out shadow raised from these
regions and I tried to approximate what
regions of the light source are visible
from this point in global illumination.
You don't need to do anything.
You just solve this equation and outcomes.
Physical reality and shadows
are parts of physical reality.
You don't need to do anything
in order to obtain shadows.
It's not like a bottom up
approach like ray tracing. So you,
you start from a baseline and you add
more and more hacks to account for more
and more effects.
And for global illumination you will see
that we will have a simple algorithm.
Hm?
Jeff can give you all this and you
don't need to account for shadows and
costings and all of these things.
Another beautiful example of costings.
This is caustics from the point
light source because for instance,
you can take a look at the shadow.
The shadows are hard.
So it's likely to be a small or a light
source. And the costings are very sharp.
So they have the same behavior
to large light sources as shadows
and another beauty with costings.
Okay,
so let's assess what these recursive,
very tracers that are capable of
doing and what they can as well.
Obviously they cannot compute,
interacted with Aisha in their activation
means to diffuse bounces or possibly
more this you cannot compute. Correct.
We'll talk about
why
and when you cannot compute
costings. Well, costings, I
have written in the future
scenes ago that it was l s s e,
so to specular PolicyCenter diffuse
because you have to go through the glass
ball and here I'm writing
something completely different.
I just say one specular balance is
necessary. The rest are optional.
Is this true or how can
we verify this is cute.
Yeah.
In order to find out if this is true or
not, I don't even need to say a word.
I can just do this.
You see the cost savings,
swollen costs in spot. Yeah. You too.
See Ya.
Yes.
Excellent.
[inaudible] no steal. Gets
my, it's my wedding ring.
Might be my fiance is going to kill me.
Okay.
You have to have seen it. Yep. Okay.
Yeah.
Nice
in
uniform.
Okay.
Okay,
so apparently rings have cost X.
Well, I start off from the light source.
I think one specular object. One,
we're like object, and then a
diffuse, which is the table.
And then Deanna and I have coffee.
So [inaudible] is enough for costs.
There's no need to prove
it in any other way.
Just take a look at physical reality
and let it be your crutch. Always.